and should we roll in a little bit for
tonight fortnite dude this looks so good
all right here we go in
five four
three four nine two podcasts
well well well
not only are we back we're all wrapped
up for christmas
shout out to abe
the conversions maybe if this doesn't
work you can become an interior designer
thank you let me get this straight a
muslim gift wrapped a juice set for
christmas how does that make sense in
any way possible
baby
what was it what was that yeah
meliana
[Music]
yeah that's how i feel melania
that's funny
first lady everybody why we gotta get
political we have so much to talk about
there's so much to talk about this is
such a huge show
just to give you a tease
we have a call in from you guys know the
tick tock guy who does the car videos
he goes hey what do you do for a living
that guy he's calling in the show isn't
that fun
i think that's really fun he's calling
in a little bit later we have so much to
talk to you about
first of all i want to say um
[Music]
oh yeah right we have sponsors we have
quip
ring and
stamps.com
now ian i know last time we talked you
had covid so i want to check in on ian
and see how he's been feeling
i mean i'm doing pretty good
all things considered you're feeling
good you're feeling normal
[Music]
that's one way to put it right
have you been having trouble breathing
or i mean just take me through your
daily routine here
you know i
wake up
and uh
i lay down
i continue to lay down
the hours drift by
and they go by some more and
then i go to bed
but i'm already in bed so i don't really
go to bed
i
i stay in bed
and
that's my life now
[Music]
all right thank you for the update i
appreciate that
so he's doing fine it sounds like he's
doing really well he's doing fine
good actually today
today marks ian's um
third year anniversary with the podcast
if you can believe that
that's why whoa
so
you know what first of all
ian in i don't know i don't think you
knew this but we were working on a ian
tribute video
to commemorate your three years of
service in the army
i mean that's very kind gesture but it
kind of feels like a
a memorial like a memorial
i was kind of afraid it might come off
that way don't say the m word or the
dewarder
all right well let's just go ahead and
roll the
virtu the visual obituary
just ignore the part where it says in
loving memory at the end
okay
all right let's celebrate ian's three
years and just to be clear it's not a
it's not a living memorial it's not a
memorial right he's alive
for now
know that i'm the only one ian you know
i would get your ass regenerate somehow
wait i'm just saying you know i would
get your ass for a deservier regeneron i
would [ __ ] pull all the stops for to
keep your ass alive you know that
shin
guy
i get you shungite
is that fda approved
not yet okay well you know what there's
ways to get everything right
all right here we go i want the record
to show that i'm the only one that
hasn't gone to the bathroom today in
this office yeah you're trying to make a
point we get it i'm really thirsty and
i'm not gonna drink
i need everyone watching to blast the
[ __ ] off okay
i'm just on that pure covet baby do you
guys know what max stands for
massive
[Music]
[Applause]
that's weird dude what are you some kind
of predator just as i predicted dude
it's lubricant silicone-based
is
[Music]
wow
[Music]
what's up
speed it up a little i'm starting to
panic a little bit
oh god i hate this part
almost done buddy you're almost there
i didn't make your [ __ ] oh i'm okay hey
i eat trapped me in here okay
he called it
the downside up he said i have to call
it that in case it tramples any
you know intellectual properties
[Music]
wash it with the water and paper towel
it down in the crevices i won't lie this
is definitely me when i'm uh
on camera
awkwardly
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
[Music]
so
what do you think what do you take me
for i can almost hear you
no don't do a memorial
you guys made it look like he died
[Music]
oh oh wait are we still going
well ian i can't say the show wouldn't
be the same without you
three years of excellence
three years of excellence ian yes thank
you
he
he will be missed rest in peace
that was powerful thank you god
three years i mean you were i feel like
you were a different guy three years ago
when you started you were yeah and now
you've really uh
you've evolved i mean you're you are
a comedic force on this show to be
reckoned with ian
oh i thought you're gonna say you really
let yourself go no you know you still
look good but i'm just saying like
you've you've evolved as a human i feel
like you came in as this hapless little
intern who i could have definitely taken
advantage of if i wanted to you know
what i mean you wouldn't have said
anything but now
not only would i dare not try that but
you just are a tour de force here on the
show
i appreciate that i started as a young
little boy and now i'm
like a machine right an actual robot
literally yeah
you started as the
as the intern
you started
doing
we're getting there
you started as an intern and now you're
just a full-blown employee dude so
yeah definitely
and you guys mentioned uh this week how
at first we had the gag of ian not
showing his face and i totally forgot
about that i know the first few months
the gag was that nobody knew who he was
because he didn't show his face and then
what was the first time you showed your
face
i feel like it was when i did the pusha
t drake thing
no no no it was when sean evans was on
and we had
the hot wings oh you came on to try the
one there was an accidental face reveal
when uh ethan bradberry came
both the bradburys yeah we weren't very
good at uh
being consistent that's right
well you know what i'm so happy that uh
you emailed us and then let's not forget
how he got the job he emailed us like 20
times yeah and then
on the 20th time i was like you know
what
i'm gonna forward this to dan
and let's see if this guy's actually
has anything redeeming to offer
he did so i'm glad you're here ian we
love you thank you i appreciate that and
i will miss you
i will
yes you know this is what tom sawyer
probably felt like when he came back to
his own funeral right right i'm still
alive tom sawyer kind of type
this could be gatorade or urine i don't
know right right
taste it
oh cause the flavor damn good
it's damn good regardless
so we congratulate you ian
and
so bad and you know the next time oh a
quick side note real quick
with my taste buds they're not even
close to coming back and sam she made me
some oatmeal uh the other morning and
she accidentally spilled like a bunch of
pepper in it
and i just said i don't give it to me
anyway i don't even matter yeah and i
had no idea oh my god
so weird
that's awesome it's kind of a super
power like did you just try eating raw
brock just go rub rock
raw brock rob broccoli
i do yeah i'd do anything i'd eat all i
did because like if i couldn't taste
anything i wouldn't eat like junk food i
just eat raw brock
you would still find a way to junk food
you think so yes i do
what's about the texture
the textures
it's about the experience hey it's about
how it makes you feel the drive-thru
okay maybe you're right
well
you know you know we have another
announcement another celebration
elo's birthday is tomorrow what a big
pimp
and i got me cupcakes to celebrate
happy birthday ela thank you
happy birthday thank you
you've done so much you've come so far
every year is an adventure with you
really is
you know that always sounds bad but no
it's good
i want to smell feet
because it almost sounds like it's so
challenging
every year no we
every year is so much activity one and
one year yeah a lot of activity here
um
cheers
so there's a lot to celebrate today
um
good so you can smell my feet tonight in
celebration of your birthday
big i'm going all out for you baby i
want to smell feet yeah i know you do
and that's why i'm saying tonight is
your special night i haven't showered my
feet i haven't washed my feet in weeks
in preparation for this
all right so you're welcome right
haven't trimmed manicured have you
visited blocked
oh
is that what you want me to arrange for
you
wow
i knew belle delphine was into that but
not you either
no but we have some fun plans
i did all kinds of surprises but she
doesn't know what it is yet but i did
all kinds of surprises for you
we could talk about it when we come back
yeah
so excited anyway now on to the obvious
elephant in the room
this is probably gonna take a while do
you want to do an average before
i'm gonna go quick like 12
minutes so i don't know um let's just
talk about it it feels weird to do it
out already all right
let me take a bite of this cupcake first
trisha would go this time
patricia is always like trying to
justify i was like this is bad
this is bad
video she goes it's asmr
oh my god
okay
[Music]
we posted a frenemies
episode with trisha
okay let me start over
yesterday we posted a frenemies episode
you know it's just it was
where where we had a a big blowout and
trisha's walk and stormed out crying
and
you know it's just it's so
it sucks because like the episode before
was great and we were simply coming back
to do a second episode because we didn't
get to do the beauty products and
somehow it just totally melted down
and
so
i honestly i don't know i mean after she
ran out
i immediately texted her and apologized
i said i'm sorry that you're so upset i
don't know what to do when you get into
like
the i don't know is it disassociative
phase or whatever where she says she
blacks out and then she like lashes out
and stuff so i was like i'm sorry i just
i don't know how to react when you get
in that way
and she said and then she sent me like a
few hours pass and she sent me this
really big beautiful apology
saying that you know
she's sorry
she says stuff she doesn't mean
she loves us in the podcast and she just
is
you know you know she has she goes into
this thing and she loses control yada
yada
and so
we had a really nice conversation and i
said you know where team i said i look i
always forgive it it's all water in the
bridge for me like i don't take anything
you say in those kind of stages
personally because i know
that you like don't have control over it
or you regret it immediately so i said
look it's all water in the bridge i'm
team tricia all the way like you know
i'm in this
and she was like thank you so much and
then you talk to her too right
yeah i so
what ethan called me
and he was like
[ __ ] hit the fan yeah i immediately
called elab come come watch the episode
so i watched it and
i just felt like um
it definitely like blew so out of
proportion over and it kind of felt like
over nothing because
i was getting um frustrated with a few
different things and
i don't know i just at some point i told
ethan like
it's it's so annoying to me when she
says stuff like oh you guys are so
unwelcoming and things like that because
i felt like it's so far from the truth
and she said
she said and i just want to make this
clear this is the kind of things that
she says that always cause problem even
in that moment she said moses doesn't
even like you guys or his family so who
cares and i was like and i said that's
why
ila doesn't want you talking about her
family or her
but um when you guys talked about it she
said well why doesn't why didn't she
just tell me directly and so
when she said that i really agreed with
that i was like i have a phone number i
should have just
messaged her directly instead of putting
you in the in between
so after the podcast i
after i watched it i felt really bad
about
seeing her like that because
i didn't take personally the stuff that
she said
i know she doesn't mean it like when she
was talking about our parenting i know
she doesn't mean that yeah
um but uh so i messaged her and i was
like you're right i should have just
talked talk to you directly and um
and she responded with a really long
message and she apologized for
everything
and i felt
like pretty good after that apology
but i don't know then today she posted
this video and i just kind of feel like
i just can't take any word like i'm used
to taking things as they are if someone
says something to me
then that's what they mean in my head
that's what i'm used to but i feel like
ever since this whole thing with trisha
and my brother being involved it's just
like i just can't handle i can't handle
it and it's like she apologized to me
really nicely but then in the video it
doesn't sound like she's that apologetic
like i expect i expected it to just be
kind of more apologetic
so
i don't know that's where i'm at
yeah it's hard because i you i get i
think what's frustrating is like you get
the sense it's like
they both tell us one thing and then
they tell each other another thing and
it's like it's like this constant
yo-yoing and it's like maddening and i
don't think you're unreasonable for
wanting to not to get a couple weeks off
yeah like you don't have to call her
immediately to resolve it it's like you
have because it was coming to
it was becoming a lot because she's
involved with my family too now you know
being with my brother yeah and so it's a
weird mix of everything and every time
like ethan said
she will throw in weird comments like
hey
he doesn't even like you guys or you
guys never call him you guys never you
don't even care about it close you don't
know anything about him and that to me
that's not true and when i brought that
up to my brother he says
she just says stuff for the show
but it's like huh i don't know if
someone repeats something so many times
it becomes true to me yeah it's it's
hard because your brother he he denies
that he reflects everything he says
she's just saying for the show she
doesn't mean it but she but this [ __ ] so
she knows it bothers you and that it's
disruptive to your family but she's so
so she keeps saying it yeah so i don't
understand what's entertaining or what's
like
what's like the entertainment value of
that
like it's not good it's not but but like
to me it seems like the only really the
only sane way you can interpret that is
that they talk about it and that's what
they talk about and she means it right
because she keeps saying it and when we
talk to her she goes no that's true
you know it's a lot
it's all so anyway we had this big
blowout because i said
she brought up something about ela and i
said we should we can't talk about ela
because uh eli doesn't want us to talk
about her and so she blew up
but it's not from this place of like oh
i'm better than her and i don't want
anyone talking about me
it's just not that it's um
it's just a lot right now because he's
involved with my brother yes and
things i've kind of hit
a fan like i
me and my brother had a little argument
and so
things weren't really going well and i
wanted a break from
you guys talking about it on the podcast
because every time it fuels everything
even more
every time you guys talk about it
things get worse
i agree and i totally understood where
you're coming from that's why
excuse me
i think it's the fact that like
she's she's dating your brother so she
needs to like
she's she can't confuse privacy a need
for privacy some measure of privacy with
like being fake
it's not fake and i think we are about
as open as it gets on the internet like
we share everything
we talk about everything but sometimes i
just need like maybe two weeks to
process what's happening you know i'm
just not ready right now
like i just had an argument with my
brother i'm not ready to talk about it
right now online you know
um it's not like i'm hiding something if
someone asked me i wouldn't say oh i
didn't argue with him you know it's not
it's not fake but the argument but you
guys have to understand the argument
isn't over trisha that's what she thinks
is like you're trying to break them up
the argument is over why is trisha
saying these things that she says you
told him and then you're denying it but
she's saying it's true and she keeps
saying it and saying and saying it and
then you're always saying
oh she's just saying it for the show
it's like well that's [ __ ] not true
or if she is just saying it for the show
why are you okay with it right you know
it's not a joke it's not a joke
it's not funny and it's not a joke it's
not entertaining to always say what kind
of sparked the whole big argument is
that on
the the last episode with the goat yoga
at the end of it she said something like
uh about them getting married and she
said something like oh he's my his mom
is not even invited yeah and that really
pissed me off and i told ethan you gotta
cut that
and um
and here i'm saying it here i'm not
hiding anything
that's what happened that for me that
crossed the line and i got upset with my
brother not at her
and um
this is that's everything i'm telling
everything right now so
no one can say i'm hiding anything
and that's it i have a lot of empathy
it's your family you know what i mean
and somehow she's gotten her wrench
she's in there with the you know i have
to give it up to trisha she has a she
has this uncanny she is a one of a kind
how she has like this ability to like
and it hurts me because i'm such a fan
of the show when it's when it's not
drama related i it's like my favorite
show i know a lot because i'm not
involved in the recording and i i get to
enjoy it just as a viewer you know i
just watch it when it's done and i have
no idea what you guys talked about and
it's really entertaining but
i'm starting to wonder you know at what
cost because
this is a bit much
right at what cost and that's the thing
is i never thought that there would be a
cost so high yeah because i feel like i
can handle her shenanigans you know
like when she was having a meltdown i
was trying to stay calm and i wasn't
taking the things that she was saying
personally there was a moment at the end
when she started calling you the c word
and she was well it wasn't it was that
plus it was like i could tell that she
was really getting emotional she started
crying and like she was just
she was boiling she was boiling over so
i told her because she said i'm gonna
leave
and i said i think it's a good idea for
you to leave and we'll talk later it
wasn't like bye [ __ ] you forever i said
you should go it wasn't going anywhere
good no it was only going worse you were
right to say that so i said why don't
you go we'll talk later when you know
because like i feel like you need to
calm down a little bit and let things
settle and then we can work it out
now on the issue of
dan how was it for you how was it you
for people were wondering right what was
it like for dan and abe
to watch that dan i remember you said
you felt like you should have left the
room or something i considered it i
don't know you should definitely not
have that would have really that would
have that would have been so odd if you
left well it just seemed i mean
it just seemed like it was getting
deeply personal and wasn't really
content anymore like it was
a real
uh thing that was uh happening between
the two of you and it i don't know i
mean i didn't yeah that was like
in my mind i was like should i slink out
of here right now
well abe what was it like for you
front row i mean i was i was just happy
dan was there
uh you were following him that's true if
it was like trust me it would have been
extra uncomfortable yeah and it'd be
there i was i was also consciously
thinking about moses i'm like i feel so
bad he's getting the pizza right now
he's thinking he's gonna show up and be
the man and then he's gonna come home
he walked through the threshold i was
like oh my god it's the meme he
literally came back and trisha greeted
him with you know
i don't care about you could dump me i
don't care [ __ ] your family i hate your
family he's like damn
i was just coming have some pizza
i was ready to bury the whole thing and
just have pizza you know what i mean and
i love people
yeah papa john i was calling
the spirit by the way papa john is gonna
be calling in next week he but that's
that's a separate thing
he's he got an update on the lawsuit and
he's gonna call into the show next we
have to give us to talk about it so
that's exciting but that's not here nor
there
people in the chat keep asking what
happened to the pizza
oh
you know what happened
we ate it
we had a whole pizza we had like a
really sad weird pizza party afterwards
it was me ap
ethan just around the counter in uh the
kitchen just like silently eating we
were all just like wow just like damn
what the hell damn this pizza is good
though but damn
and in case you were wondering they did
bring the thick crust
they they got the note about the crust
that
i felt like [ __ ] that night yeah way too
much yeah it [ __ ] me up so much
terrible man you know the thick crust
was not a good call because it's like so
failing but it was so greasy there was
then there's the aspect of like okay we
have this footage
is it should we even upload it what's
the deal so
anyway dan put it online unlisted and
then when trisha messaged me
we talked it out and everything
and she said
well we knew it would like get a lot of
views obviously
but the question was like
basically
there's the question of like
is this fair to upload it is it too much
to upload it for me it felt like this is
the this is the lore of the show this is
the whole show if you don't upload this
you're missing a huge puzzle piece
but i wasn't gonna upload it without her
permission so when we were talking she
brought it up and she said well at least
i hope you've got good footage and i
said i have it unlisted do you want to
watch it and she said no you can upload
it but as long this was her condition
she says as long as nothing's edited out
that was her condition she said you
should upload it as long as nothing's
edited out and she wanted it she
literally wanted me to upload it
she said you should upload it and i said
all right
so we uploaded it and
[Applause]
um
i do think it's important that we upload
it because like how could you possibly
explain what happened otherwise right
so then we i think we fixed it and we
resolved it obviously the comments were
pretty brutal to her
you know
and but so so i thought we were all good
and f you know what ironically
dr drew was is scheduled to come back
next week i know and we are all supposed
to be in that episode but now i don't
see how we can do it so next so dr drew
was scheduled to be back
on tuesday we're going to do an episode
with everybody with all the crew tricia
and moses and ela
and we all already submitted a
personality test we were going to get
our results of our personality test but
now
it's just going to turn into like an
episode of jerry springer
ellis said and i think she's right
yeah you know what i mean because if
ela's there moses is there and tristan's
not there it's going to turn into an
episode of jerry springer yeah hit that
ring give me the ring sound bite zach
ding ding ding
will you throw punches with trish aila
oh god i'm not going to participate
like frenemies i don't like jerry
springer right
yeah that's the sound
so you know like on one hand we could
just have dr drew to come mediate again
which it probably makes sense maybe i
was really excited about the personality
test
but maybe we could have him come mediate
and then do the personality test later
it's
it's not just him it's his partner and
oh they were all scheduled
yeah [ __ ] it's like a it's a whole thing
so well we should discuss after the show
so we definitely need to follow through
with that i guess the question is if
trisha will be there or not right
i mean i would like her to be there it's
just a matter of like if trisha and
eliza is going to be on the camera it
seems i don't know if trish is going to
be able to help herself
not just her me too i get very emotional
and i would not be able to keep calm
like ethan did and i just don't want to
put myself in that situation i agree and
i don't want you to have to do something
you're not comfortable with either
well it sounds like we're gonna have to
go through it one way or the other
so then to think so but i thought like
we had this really nice texting
conversation where she's like i forgive
or i'm sorry and i was like i forgive
you it's all good i'm team trisha you
know me like i don't
and so then she uploads a video today
you know explaining
what happened from her perspective
which is fine it's what i i kind of
expected her to put out a video you know
why is it so hard to find her channel on
youtube hang on one sec
um
you know but but she said certain things
in the video that kind of rubbed me
wrong in his
counter to to what we talked about on
the phone for example
she pinned a freaking comment that says
she pinned this comment it says people
keep praising ethan ila but to be honest
they're just as toxic as david and his
gang was they poke tricia in ways that
they know will get a rise out of her and
don't fully communicate with her there's
a lot of underlying passive
aggressiveness and condescension and
their interaction with trisha and nobody
calls them out for it so i mean i don't
really know
first of all i totally disagree with
that yeah comment yeah
and so when she pinning like when she's
actually feeling like that i don't know
how we it makes me feel like i don't
know how we can go on if that's how she
feels well especially when she messages
me and apologizes and says it's all good
and then she makes a video saying that
we're toxic now i don't know anything
about her relationship with david
and that gang
but the this insinuation that we're
toxic to her or that we don't
communicate with her or that we poke her
trying to do you know get her it's just
it's just not true i don't know what's
your evidence of that
like
i mean i just don't get i just don't get
it i really don't
so i mean i'd like to find
i'd like to find an
example i mean i don't know it just i
just was like
abe you watched the video i mean it's 15
minutes long it was one up this morning
so i haven't had time to watch it so
it's not like i'm about
oh i meant 15 minutes long if i whatever
i said maybe like what was the thrust of
this video
it was back and forth a lot you know she
did feel bad um but she did say that you
know she made it seem like you poke at
her on purpose to get a reaction
and um
i don't know i mean i
i don't know it went back and forth a
lot but she did kind of make it seem
like you're provoking it on purpose
let's see that's the thing is like we
have this show where we provoke each
other and now all of a sudden me doing
that is toxic and uh you know
and and and somehow it's like that's the
whole premise right that we make fun of
each other i don't know a single
instance where i've where i'm talk i'm
being toxic to her people are praising
ethan neil but they're just as toxic as
dave and his gang was what did i do i've
literally tried my best to support her
and welcome her and and do everything
that i possibly can to be forgiving and
accepting and to welcome her back every
time i don't hold anything against her
and this insinuation that she thinks i'm
toxic i just feel like she's weaving
this narrative already and it makes me
wonder
if this thing can possibly work out that
comment at first i was like okay we'll
be back everything's fine we'll get over
it when i read that comment i was like
ah
i don't know if this is gonna work out i
really don't and it's a shame because i
love the show it's what the [ __ ] it's
the show's the best right like it's like
everybody loves the show it's like crack
everybody loves it
but what the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
you know what i mean like
she also mentioned a few times that we
have final cut and so that okay please
the narrative i've literally never cut
the only thing that we've ever we don't
we don't like censor it
i mean
the only thing i've ever cut out was in
the last episode she went on and on and
on and on about the family and i said
you know what this is not good i'm gonna
cut this out for the sake of ela and her
family it had nothing in fact if
anything it made her look better because
she was saying some real [ __ ] vile
[ __ ] about moses family and if you ask
me every time she's in front of the
camera she's doing everything she can to
drive a wedge between moses and his
family
yes
that is my problem
like she's doing maybe it's unconscious
i don't know but she's doing everything
she possibly can to drive a wedge
between moses and his family
like a comment that his mom would not be
invited to the wedding i mean where's
where would something like that come
from he said she's joking uh what's the
joke here exactly what's the joke i love
comedy
you know what's the joke what's the joke
yeah is is is ila's mom supposed to
think that's a joke
people are supposed to just watch them
like oh it's just trisha she doesn't
mean it
when when she says oh you don't know
your brother you your brother doesn't
care about you you guys don't you guys
aren't even close when she says that 20
times what's the joke
and you know what's messed up is like
before they started dating we were
really close with mo's i mean now
we were really close with those we saw
him every weekend we talked about
everything i confided to him all the
time we talked about what he was going i
mean we were closer to him than anyone
else in our family yeah
is
the siblings that i'm the closest to but
i mean if anything since he started
dating her he would not participate in
like our family calls or stuff like that
but that's fine i figured he's busy i
don't i don't have a problem with that
but i it sucks when she puts it in a
narrative where it's like they don't
even care about you they don't even call
you it's like that's not true it's total
[ __ ]
but i don't know so i don't know and at
one point it's like
oh god [ __ ] gerd
at what point
is she really is this thing that we're
doing actually causing too much harm to
our family you know what i mean
so it's like it's not just funds and
games anymore it's actually become kind
of really bad
so that's where i'm at and i don't know
what to do because it's awesome and i
love it but like she's i don't know i've
i don't know when she's pinning comments
about i'm toxic and [ __ ] and like
i just i don't know what to make of that
and like it just makes me feel like i
don't know if that if she'll ever
actually be able to stop trying to
alienate moses from his family
and friends and his and his employees by
the way people he works with she does
that to them too which is a whole
different story
so
god damn it
no i'm okay
can i just clarify something
from my own conscience because i've seen
some of the comments saying at the end
when i sat next to ethan and i said i've
been waiting for this moment i was just
playing off the simp mean i met i meant
like sitting next to ethan i didn't mean
waiting for her to come that was fine
i didn't think anything of it are you
kidding huh yeah it was great
i was just trying to gather my thoughts
i just was hit by a train
so i wanted to see you put the bird poop
on your
face you know what's funny is we only
made it through three [ __ ] products
yeah and not even the good ones man
we had so many good ones lined up what
what was that tumeric like like was it
nasty
yeah it's disgusting
you'd have to be insane to do any of
those things if you actually think any
of those things work you're just crazy i
don't know what to say brushing your
teeth with strawberry i mean what the
[ __ ] are you talking about
the saying is like so dumb so i don't
know i mean
in my heart
i still want to try to make it work with
her
but
like
because like the arch of the of our
relationship was like we started
we had a big blowout
and then we came back and we were
friends for a while
and then out of nowhere there was this
huge blowout again over the fact that
ila wanted some privacy because she's
always making these little jabs at the
family
and now that's blown up
because she can't respect the fact that
ella doesn't that she needs to there
needs to be boundaries and it's not that
we're hiding [ __ ] it's just you can't
talk about his family like that every
episode you can't do it i mean if it's
just a joke then let's not joke about it
you know i don't know i just don't get
those comments
i totally i don't get what are they what
is the purpose of those comments you
know the only the only thing it achieves
is that it's alienating him from his
family yeah
and there's it's only so long before
moses can be like
oh she doesn't mean she doesn't mean she
doesn't mean it it's all good i don't
feel that way i didn't say that to her
it doesn't mean it there's only so many
times he can say that before you like
that's why we got into an argument
because i i came to the point of feeling
like i i just it doesn't matter what
you're gonna say to me
when i keep hearing from her that you
hate us and you don't like us and
all this stuff it's uh tainting my image
of you
and the way it's hurting my feelings
i don't know i just can't
it's
i don't know what to say yeah
that's about it i mean that's about it i
think we said it all
so
hey guys what's up so
i
it's friday morning so it's i don't know
but
so that's i mean that's everything right
i don't know what else to say
so
what
it was good pizza
at least no it really wasn't
well it didn't taste good i mean it
tastes good
yeah it tasted good it tastes good right
then it was okay yeah it's too greasy i
think it was the i think that they need
to go back to the kitchen and
reformulate something because the level
of grease is out of control
i personally think that the dealt my doe
request ruined it
it was too nice
might have yeah i think i ruined it
all right well we have a call in with
the cargo that's that bad with daniel
mack
uh we should do but let's do some ads
first yeah okay let's talk about uh
where's that quipped gum
is this it it's right next to you little
metal thing that's gum yeah quip has got
gum now dude it's sick so i just had a
yeah that is fancy as [ __ ] how does this
[ __ ] work
so quip uh here can you email the copy
to
i did you got it it's not i don't have
access to my email on this computer
you have to do
how does this work
is there not i don't think it's loaded
dan
oh it's like it's like a pez dispenser
okay
so it's probably in the bag
so you have it it says today's reads
the top of the inbox okay this is a
disaster i don't see the copy either dan
oh here it is i got it i got it okay
well can you can you i don't see the
bag um can you feel the gum
all right
quip baby you know we love quip and i
just had a uh here let me have a cup
about a
cupcake bite maybe you shouldn't i gotta
clean my mouth with whip gum
i gotta give you a review of how the gum
works
all right
all right
[Music]
brush floss or chew gum
can you imagine if you could just chew
gum instead of brush
gum is this unsung hero when it comes to
better oral health
they didn't send gum they just sent the
dispensers
what what's in this
other dispensers quip didn't send us gum
they just sent us the dispenser for real
you're sure there's no gum in there
what the [ __ ]
i want to try the gum
wait how are they going to send just a
dispenser there's got to be gum in there
that doesn't look like it
what the [ __ ] are you sure there's no
gun how could you send just a dispenser
like how is that even possible
well i'm sure it's
that
great
really cool
look at this you don't you've triple
checked because they're going to email
us being like you didn't do the cub we
sent you the gum
you just look really good
okay let me tell you about chewing gum
like a press dispenser gum is the unsung
hero when it comes to better oral health
the american dental association
recommends chewing sugar-free ground for
20 minutes after meals that's awesome
gum is something people chew as a way to
relieve stress curb appetite and most
importantly freshen breath but many
don't realize that gum can also be an
integral part of a healthy oral care
routine
by the way you gotta love the pez
dispenser i love it i love love love
love love love love love love love love
love love life
you put you just
oh my god this is amazing yeah i love it
this is amazing
i love quip gum
oh it's perfect during perfect you don't
need to touch anything right elo
we all chew gum but not all gum is
created equal some might come in fancy
packaging some might not come at all but
they only cover up the bad breath others
are loaded with sugar that can wreak
havoc on your teeth luckily the oral
care experts equip have made a gob that
stands out from the back
one that can help prevent cavities oh
and it tastes great too
it does
it's only a few short years ago the quip
reinvented the toothbrush for modern age
they've done it again with chewing gum
they've launched a new gum that's
actually good for your oral health and
comes with a dispenser to remind you
that it's one click candy you loved as a
kid that's true love it true whip gum
can help prevent cavities and freshen
breath with chewing for 20 minutes after
each meal it's sugar-free has a
tooth-friendly
xylitol with zero calories and to
satisfy your taste buds quite added a
long lasting minty flavor crunchy
tri-layer design and stamped it all with
the classic equip tongue
the slim travel ready dispenser
available in five colors packs and
protects up to 10 gum pieces at a time
and fits in just about any person or
pocket for the go in a world where we
all need to be extra safe with hygiene
the quick release button means you can
still share with friends no rapper hands
or hassle good observation elo
you know what i'm saying you can get a
gum refill for a gift that keeps on
giving all year round quips
customizationable uh subscription that
you chew and share at your own pace and
not worry about running out plus the
more you buy the more you save with bulk
discounts on extra gum packs let's go
this is not a substitute for brushing
and flossing but it is a great support
for your oral health pair it with quip
electric toothbrush refillable floss and
more great products right now and the
special holiday deals fits fits great in
a stocking
in addition gun packs whip delivers
fresh brush heads floss toothpaste
refills every three months for five
dollars shipping is free and you can
save money and skip the misery of
in-store shopping right the f now so go
to get quipped dot com slash h3 right
now and get a free plastic dispenser
with any refill plan
that's a free dispenser at get quip dot
com slash hd spell g-e-t-q-u-y-p dot com
slash h3 it's quip the good habits
company all right
i like that
i like that gum i've always loved pez
dispenser it's always been like the best
treat ever so satisfying to do that
can we just do this whole episode i like
it
so should we do another ad or
let's do the call and then i'll do
another out i feel bad like come on
maybe i'll do one more real quick let's
see yeah do one more
okay
is he lined up
uh actually no line them up baby
we sent yeah just go ahead do another
you want to do let's do ring we like
ring i love ring
listen ring doorbell it's the [ __ ] okay
you put it up and the [ __ ] rules i
wrote the dead [ __ ] rule
all right ring you don't have to sell so
hard i'm right there with you i love it
you know
it's doorbell season the busiest time of
the year at your front door and that's
definitely true at my house they wrote
that but it's just amazon
i live in a gated community so you know
no foot traffic
right now there's more
schmutz and schmatt's at your door let's
i don't need coffee to promote
i mean ring
listen here's the deal with the ring i
love it and i use it and it's one of my
favorite products for sure
the doorbell here's here's the thing
about ring it gives you a motion
detector when someone comes close to
your ring doorbell or spotlight whatever
product you have you get a notification
on your phone you pull it up you see
what's going on
amazing
also it beams the video up to the cloud
so if anything happens
you've got the evidence and the record
of it happening boom now if somebody's
at your door or somebody's up to
shenanigans you could talk to them
through your phone through the ring
device
incredible still
there's also a live view so if you're
wondering if a package arrived or
some shenanigans is going on around your
house
you can live view it i will say they
didn't have live view at first but they
updated it like a year or two ago and
that made it pretty much the complete
package yeah so like i would be at our
old house i was super paranoid because
we people are always messing with us
there i'd be upstairs and i'd hear
something and i pull up the ring live i
had them all around our house and i was
like you know it's so it's so great and
then the other thing that i love is that
they've got the the ring
neighborhood app so that everyone who
has a ring in your neighborhood gets
access to this app built into the app
where you can see reports and stuff and
you can see all these crazy whining
cairns and stuff who are like they
complain they're like they're like
here's a picture of someone who's trying
to rob my house and like that was a dude
literally delivering food that's like
it's like so entertaining there's like
someone who's super paranoid and then in
the comments everybody's slamming on
them
but then there's some really useful
information as well
ring is a one-of-a-kind product it's
honestly giving me the peace of mind the
sense of security and everything that
you would want from and i'll tell you we
had the the ordinary um
security cameras yeah the old-school one
it's just it's not even oh useless it's
so useless like you have to have like a
recording device and you have to wire it
all through it it's like you can't
access it when you hear something i mean
it's really
and it's way more expensive i'm telling
you ring is is the future is the only
thing you need
love it
for a limited time go to ring.com
forward slash h3 for special holiday
offers that's ring.com
h3 alrighty
beautiful
so we have uh so who we're going to talk
to now you guys got them lined up yeah
uh so daniel mack some of you got here
let's watch some of his videos to
refresh because he's kind of a
phenomenon on tick tock i love his
videos and i and
i'm sure certainly not the only one
because every time
when he makes these videos he goes hey
what do you do for a living like the
vast majority of people go hey you're
that guy from tick tock okay
it's not loading though
how's our internet
we're still broadcasting yeah you're up
good old tick tock tick tock tick tock
it's always tick-tock
it's always usually loads though
you know yeah i don't know
do it live
oh this is annoying why isn't it working
does it work for anyone else when they
open it
working for me
it is so what the [ __ ] here let me open
a different browser
what the
[ __ ] here let me try and like incognito
well do it live [ __ ] it
yeah exactly
well okay why is that okay incognito
works so here here's this type of video
okay it doesn't play you guys seriously
i mean i'm trying to do a show here i'm
doing the best i can
okay
yeah yeah i saw tacos still tacos okay
man
what do you do for a living
i'm an engineer engineer yeah hell yeah
thank you
work in finance finance morgan stanley
morgan stanley cool man i appreciate it
thank you i'm an aviation advisor
aviation advisor
fighter pilot i think i've seen you on
youtube
that's me yeah
thanks man
what do you do what do you do
director of sales okay hell yeah man i
appreciate it thank you
they banned him for five years for
filming what
come on everybody loved it
how they can enforce that so anyway he's
he these are his videos and i think he
really tapped into something special
because i think we all have that
question when we see someone in a really
nice car it's like what yeah what did
they do who are they right i feel like
especially since i moved to l.a like
in israel you rarely see nice cars but
here it's all the time literally
everyone's so normal
to see like
super high-end cars yeah and i always
wonder what do all these people do i
agree because like our job is like one
in a trillion yeah
it's like this but then all these
[ __ ] are out there it's like what
how do you how do you make money
let's bring them on cool
daniel mack bringing him on right now
one sec
oh i see him
hey can you hear me yeah i can hear you
can you see and hear us video
i can see you oh this is pretty high
tech i didn't know we were doing a zoom
call yes sir
look at us so let me pin let me pin can
i pin can you pin dan
yeah
no it's that it's dan it's a dan thing
no you can do it
here yeah the little the little box on
your laptop screen yeah i got it oh i
see i see
so how are you my dude
i'm doing good i'm doing good good
weather over here in dallas so
so how did you're in dallas
yeah people think i'm in l.a yeah
yeah i didn't know i didn't know there's
so many nice cars in dallas but i guess
there's rich people everywhere
oh yeah old money new money in dallas so
i don't know so
tell me about the first one of these
videos you made was it uh your intention
to make this kind of video how did it
come together
i mean i just kind of thought of the
idea during the summer and then i
actually moved to dallas uh just a
couple months ago actually for a job and
i had the idea but i was with a friend
driving around and we went to this like
really like rich area uh and saw like a
ferrari and a lamborghini just like
parked there and i was like it's now or
never so i whipped out my camera i had
like 20 followers on tick tock at the
time and i just posted the video like
thinking nothing of it and then it just
popped off like same day i was like what
yeah immediately i guess that just goes
to show the power of a great idea yeah
are people i'm i'm kind of surprised by
how receptive everybody is but are do
you just cut out the rude people are
everyone just really happy to talk to
you
it could be a texas thing but like 90 of
people i talk to are just really nice
like
i don't yeah i don't include people that
aren't like some people will be like
don't put me in the videos and whatnot
or they'll just ignore me and drive away
and i'm just standing there with my
camera like uh okay but yeah most are
really nice uh so it must be a texas
thing because i did that in like new
york or something i i don't think people
hey forget it but hey [ __ ] you buddy
your mom
i'm kind of surprised
it seems like all the answers are
relatively boring right you expect like
i do this incredible thing but like i'm
in finance
a few of them are like drug dealers
sometimes i think people are joking how
many people do you think are actually
drug dealers when they say that
there's one guy i mean the first guy
that did it uh in my first video he said
drug dealer and that's kind of what
popped it off but he's like a car i
think he like rents out exotic cars but
there's another guy in a ferrari that i
got in like my fifth video and he just
plain face i roll up to him i say what
do you do and he just looks at me dead
in the eyes and says i'm a drug dealer i
was like uh and he's like yup
maybe that got serious i think the truth
is the people who say i'm in real estate
are the actual drug dealers
yeah yeah there's some shady stuff for
sure going on okay but it just it's
actually a really interesting insight
into like how these people get so rich
it's like a real estate real estate real
estate oh dude
i think i'm getting i think i'm getting
the pattern here
yeah definitely yeah multiple streams of
income i guess i don't know they i guess
they have so much stuff going on
sometimes they don't even know what to
say that's true
yeah
so when you blow off
blood blow
blah up on tick tock
um
does it mean like financial success too
or is it just kind of like
you're just cool on tick tock but
i don't know
i'm expanding it i don't know you know
tick tock has like their creator fund
and it's pretty minute i don't know i
mean i've made decent money off of it
but i think like youtube's where the
where i'm trying to shift a little bit
more into or something but something's
going to come of it yeah i'm waiting for
you get a sponsor from some car
people you know what i mean like
i want some car brand to buy me yeah
let's go
be like because i drive like a chevy
impala like people think i drive like a
ferrari or something
but i drive a 2011 chevy impala so i'm
like
if you're watching this buy me a car or
something good advertising for you yeah
we gotta get your ass uh a nice car
well
keep at it i think there is definitely
something there for you you know and um
what's like the most interesting
experience you've had asking people that
sticks out to you
well one guy it was like my third video
he was driving a uh a bentley actually i
guess i didn't end up putting him in
because the audio was a little weird but
it was around that time when i shot that
third video some guy uh i asked him and
he's like why why are you asking me this
and i was like well it's for a tick tock
and he's like i like your spirit i want
you to come to my mansion christmas
party this
is actually this weekend so i might be
doing that but he's like yeah i have a
two day rolling mansion party uh with
like a bunch of rich people and i own
like 20 cars bring your friends let's
going to end up in a dungeon bro
[Laughter]
you're going to be the sacrifice you're
going to be the party sack human
sacrifice
well honestly i've gotten like seven job
offers too like really just like i like
your spirit here's my video
that's some rich people [ __ ] right there
i like your spirit son i'd like to offer
you a job so nobody bought your soul yet
did you get any good job offers or were
they kind of like i'll pass
well last week some guy rolled up i
rolled up to him in a ferrari i don't
know if you've seen my videos because i
walk up to him asking the question he
doesn't say anything about him knowing
them but he's like i'm looking for a
manager actually for my fine for like my
financial company or something like that
real estate like are you like are you
interested immediately and i was like
wait what he's like yeah like here's my
business card here's my number give me a
ring i'm looking for managers i was like
man i just asked this question you don't
even know who i am i think i think you
tapped into something they're important
because it reminds me of that scene from
uh
the one with [ __ ] leonardo and
the
both of wall street
where uh jonas jonah hill's character
goes what do you do for a living like i
just you know i want to do what you do i
want to make and i think people in that
high level they want really motivated
people and it doesn't you find it
doesn't really matter what's their
background or experience but if you show
that go-get they're like i want this guy
oh definitely yeah it's been weird i
don't know like that i'm a normal person
i just happened to blow up for no reason
so my friends like no reason come on
someone we got lucky
so you're gonna be taking any of the job
offers or no
i work a different job right now they
don't want me talking about it too much
but uh i work in finance so oh look at
you dude why are you driving around in a
chevy impala bro
i just graduated just graduated
you'll be fine you're you've got that
and you've got the entrepreneurial
spirit you're going to be one of those
people yeah you're going to be in one of
those before too long
and so some young kids going to be
coming up to be like hey sir what do you
do for a living
well son
i'm going to find them
they'll be like what do you do i'm like
well i asked people what they do for a
living yeah and that development leads
me to get a ferrari i guess that's the
most ironic thing
yeah cool
i saw a video where the guy invited you
into his car to drive it
oh yeah yeah that guy was so chill um he
was like hyped to see me uh he let me
like take photos in front of his car he
messaged me after but uh i was so scared
doing that because you have to like
shift it by oh yeah
use the triggers on the handle to get it
you should have just floored it and
[ __ ] crushed it and then bounced
oh for real i was i was real scared i
went like 50 miles out
was not it was not going to be flooring
it but uh i don't know i've had a couple
people offer to let me drive their stuff
so
how do you find these cars you just go
to rich areas and like stand around
yeah well i got banned from like the
place that i went to the most for five
years have you heard about i just saw i
literally just saw that before i brought
you on
yeah yeah so like i'm there just you
know filming as i do for the last month
and three cops pulled me aside and
they're like come with me sir come with
me and i'm like with a friend i'm like
what's going on here and they're like
you're criminally trespassing right now
like we can write you a ticket and
arrest you right now and i was like whoa
what do you mean they're like the
property owners don't want you here they
they said that you're banned from the
property they take my mug shot with like
an ipad
oh what i didn't know they could do that
yeah they're like turned to the side and
i was like is this necessary
if people are watching me like in this
rich area like pointing i got three cars
like caught on me you got to flex on
your friends because you got all these
rich friends now you got to start a war
you got to start a war you have
influence
village there there i called them up and
i tried to get a you know something i
was like why did this happen they said
someone complained so what's the name of
it
highland park village highland park
village you all heard it right here foot
soldiers assemble highland park village
in dallas texas you'll regret the day
you ban daniel mack from your facilities
foot soldiers rise up
let's call them live right now can we
call them
no dan says it's a bad idea
either either you'll get unbanned or
they're really they're going to extend
your ban for another five years after
exactly we're going to cause a mob to
bombard them you should make a trip out
to la and do one here because i feel
like you see a lot of i think people are
generally nice i think they're just like
they're proud right they're they're
happy to tell you they're proud of of
everything they've they've acquired
yeah i'm actually going to be going to
la tomorrow to do a collab with a big
creator so oh [ __ ] there you go shit's
happening bro but it's going to be yeah
it's going to be a good one so i think
i'm going to go like rodeo drive like
stuff like that that's really cool yeah
yes yes yes yes every other car there is
always like a yellow lamborghini or
something there yeah
yeah it's free free money over there
well daniel yeah it's free money just
buy back dropping out of the sky
well danielle i'll be watching on tick
tock
all righty i appreciate it thanks for
calling in buddy appreciate you
god bless what was the name one more
time at that facility
uh highland park village highland park
village we're coming for you they need
to reverse we're coming for you
[ __ ] the foot soldier
tell them daniel sent ya
[Laughter]
all right daniel take care buddy
appreciate you man bye
nice guy
very cool i love people like him it's
just such a great idea yeah he's feet
he's got a great idea he's
fearless and he just gets in there here
i want to watch another one of his this
one has 40 million views
yeah so he's super viral on tick tock
i think yeah i've seen this one
40 million bro that's sick
i think he scares the [ __ ] out of this
guy living
nothing nothing
excuse me what do you do for a living
they think they're getting mugged what
are you doing
i'm married
okay that's what's up
[Music]
okay i appreciate it what do you do for
a living
oh uh medical clinics medical clinics
yeah i appreciate it man thank you okay
in other words he sells he sells
oxycontin in rural america
medical clinic
that guy's the real drug dealer
hey man
this guy's my favorite yeah he's like
what the [ __ ]
and then it's also maybe the kobe like
everyone's gonna
i think that was before kovid
i don't think so oh he's wearing a mask
yeah he has a mask on him
i mean if i'm walking in my car and
someone jumps at me with a camera in my
face i'd be like the [ __ ]
yeah too
what do you do for a living what would i
say i'd be like
well i'm kind of a big deal on the
internet
you don't recognize me
yeah
[Music]
every one of those car meetups i've ever
been to because i used to go to them a
lot everyone's just kind of dicky from
my experience maybe it's just an la
thing
no i think well
i think i think there might be some on
to that you know i mean certainly takes
a certain personality to drive around in
a car like that
you know
so oh we have a calling now from the
only fans girl we have make ethan laugh
we have so many crazy videos you guys
want to watch some videos is the end
still ian are you alive
i'm hanging
in there you are
wait ian actually i i am actually
curious how are your symptoms how are
you doing i mean you have kovit i am
worried about you he's hacking [ __ ]
how are you feeling for real though um
i'm all right it's a i got a bad cough
there's covet everywhere
yeah i know you could you could all over
this you could can that air and [ __ ]
you know what i mean yeah
and you haven't left your room right
if you bring a potted plant in here
it'll just
uh
no i haven't left this room
is that crazy
are you going crazy
[Music]
oh my god you can't even talk
are you getting better are you still
like
do you feel that you're you're getting
better at all or are you still bad
i think i'm getting better
i think they said i'm allowed to go out
that's insane that's insane
i can tell that's not true
yeah
somebody like all right 10 days is up
let's go shopping
i want to just slowly let the air out of
this air mattress
poor guys on an air mattress oh my god
i'm sinking just like my ambition
you're deflating the air mattress right
now
you don't have to do that for us
i'm going down
i'm going down with the ship what have
you been eating since you can't taste
anything have you been enjoying the food
at all
mush
it's all mush
it's all mush there's no flavor
just like
life
oh what have you been eating though
that's mushy
you know
i don't even remember
doesn't matter it all blurs together god
bless
all right
well
all right thanks for the update
show the long shot of him sunk into his
bed though
like not zoomed in
[Applause]
ian really goes all out he he deflated
his bed for us for christ's sake
i've never seen him smile so much right
kobe has been good for you ian is there
any truth to covet being good for you
can we make that argument
don't get covered ladies and gentlemen
okay
because everyone was saying the covet
ian was super funny
what are your thoughts about being
funnier with covet than without
corona
well you know
um you know
people said that it was
it would be a drama but it's a comedy
got it
like the joker
[Applause]
kofi turned in into the joker
so let's do our last ad
and then
one laugh
oh i wanted to say you guys go watch our
jared leto content chord it came out
really good it was really fun
[Applause]
we posted the frenemies and everybody
left our freaking content court to go
watch frenemies told you that they're
like [ __ ] this
this is way
he shared better so bad
can we watch the video of him laughing
yeah let's do it
here let me pull it up on youtube
what is going to get us claimed there
might be copyrighted music in it
here i got it
i just i'm going to mute it i need a
machine gun
dude i'm sorry bro
[Music]
i'm sorry i just don't accept that first
of all that cast is really bad the joker
is not a model you know what i mean
right he's not some hunk that's like
just a little edgy and wild he's a
[ __ ] maniac and he's not handsome you
know what i mean
yeah i can't do this
so watch that that was good let's do
what's our last one stamps
uh that's right stamps you all know the
holiday season more people will be
mailing stuff than ever before that
means the post office is going to be
busy
you don't have time for that sams.com
brings the post office and now ups
shipping right to your computer mail and
ship anything from the convenience of
your home or office with stamps.com
anything you can do at the post office
you can do with just a few clicks
stamps.com saves you money with deep
discounts that you can't even get at the
post office why would you even go to the
post office instead of stamps.com i mean
it's like a suicide mission going to the
post office these days yeah yeah
you shouldn't oh i mean the post office
is great but you know stamps is just
more convenient
sams.com brings the service of the u.s
postal service and ups right to your
computer stamps.com is a must-have for
any business whether you're small just
sending outgoing invoices or an online
seller fulfilling orders with
record-setting holiday season or even a
giant warehouse sending thousands of
packages a day stamps.com can handle it
all with ease simply use your computer
to print official us postage 24 7 for
any letter any package any class email
anywhere you want once your mail is
ready just schedule a pickup or drop it
off it's that it's that zipple folks
with stance.com you get five cents off
every first class stamp and up to 40 off
priority mail and up to 62
off ups shipping not to mention it's a
fraction of the cost of this expensive
postage meters i still know what that
means i've done this copy a bunch of
times i don't know what a postage meter
is but maybe some of you guys out there
doing
sams.com is a no-brainer save you time
and money it's no wonder over nine
hundred thousand small businesses
already use stamps.com
don't spend one minute of your holiday
season at the post office this year sign
up at stamps.com instead there's no risk
and with our promo code h3 you get a
special offer that includes a four-week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale
no long-term commitment or contracts
just go to stamps.com click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
and type h3 that stamps.com enter
h3stamps.com never go to the post office
again
all right
[Applause]
we love you guys
so um
let's do let's get let's get the um
oh there's so many good videos we have
two more columns but yeah let's watch
some videos there's some really good
ones in here ela that i think you're
gonna love
so you guys know we are fascinated with
scooter people it's been a while
and i think i thought i'd seen it all
so what's happening is he stuck in the
store
oh my god it is
oh right there oh but maybe it's locked
why is it so windy bro
does he just bail
oh he goes back in
he's not done that nothing's a tank yeah
is this jared leto is the joker yeah i'd
be way better oh he already broke
another window it looks like oh
dude that guy just had a whole shower of
glass that he was unfazed by
look how much look how much glass fell
on him
here let's do a slow-mo of this
touchpoint style let's watch that back
in slow motion
dude the amount of glass this guy takes
a shower in unfazed
i get jackass done it's crazy damn
he's pretty badass though what the what
the
bandanna and the glasses
that's pretty good that's pretty cool to
be honest this is your brain on scooter
any questions
yeah guys something man
[Applause]
okay ela you'll appreciate this so this
guy is this a famous streamer
uh i think so yeah he said he had like
40 000 people watching yeah
you know who he is a.b
i forget his name i have seen him around
though i think he's primarily known for
like pokemon and nintendo
he's playing pokemon
so so dude went during the stream and
pissed in the bathtub
okay
why i guess because it's faster i just
peed in my basement faster than the
toilet
good question i don't know but but the
girlfriend comes in and she's like i
told you not to pee in the bathtub it's
disgusting oh my god so he's done it
he's done it many times and she's just
like i can't do it i can't with you
mods can you buy me a splitter yeah
[Music]
oh cause i peed
i peed in the bathtub i'm sorry
dude
you are disgusting bro
he's like please don't do this i'm sorry
i don't know
this is it's not like an adhd like
so so let me get this straight you have
to roast me in front of twenty seven
thousand people yeah because multiple
times so it's so it's time to shoot in
my basement
yes bro yes it's time to it's time to
shame you
once is okay you do it once she tells
you to stop yes bro peeing in your
bathtub when you live with a girl who
doesn't want you to pee in a bath it's
time to shame you bro
what does that save you from like i
don't understand if you already went to
the bathroom you're already there i'm
trying to think maybe okay so so if i'm
charting this out in my mind maybe the
shower doesn't have the toilet in it as
it's closer to him so he runs in and
he's in the tub he's in his basement i
mean it's always near each other you
know this guy needs a drain in his room
that you can just pee in i just peed in
my bed i don't see an issue that he
can't make it to the toilet nearby he's
streaming you know [ __ ] you gotta get it
done so so love just messaged and said
that's mischief and he thinks it's a bit
what what he thinks it's fake there's no
way she's acting love you really think
stat
he just he just messaged me and he said
that can we get love on i'm not taking
him on let's call him get love to call
on i'm gonna take away this i don't see
any issue what's wrong with peeing in
the bathtub
wait what that way
hey what
what's wrong with peeing in the bathtub
what i don't understand the black one
that is gross okay but like you you have
water that goes down and you can are you
gonna clean it after you pee in there
hold on jack
it doesn't just clean itself
i understand
[Laughter]
first of all there's
being in the shower is one thing
if you pee in the tub it sits there
but there's a drain i don't
understand the issue with that but the
pee it gets over the top so if you're
gonna stick to it so if you live with a
girl
and she's going to take a shower and
there's a bunch of urine sitting there
in the tub you think that's okay to do
to her
no but i i'm saying you can piss in the
drain and then just you know flush it
down didn't do that water he didn't do
that oh so there was just like urine
just all over that's what he did oh okay
love says he doesn't have a cam set up
but he can join the call and just talk
yeah that's okay
i had a roommate that puked in his tub
regularly or just once no just once but
it doesn't go down
the dangle the toilet's right there he
didn't clean it up and then his
girlfriend cleaned it like the next day
he just left it and had her see that's
why i asked zach like are you gonna
clean it because you know
you know he's not and then i would i
would clean it okay when i was younger
uh like four or five years old i had
this toy chest
and i used to pee in there
why
wait whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
toy chest
how did you clean it you just transport
it to the bathroom no there was like a
bunch of toys in it and i would just
take a piss on it
when i was like four or five years old
you know when you're young you do weird
[ __ ] yeah you don't know sure you do but
that is still funny it's true but
the bathroom was like right there but
you know i just wanted to pee on my toys
for some reason did you pee in your room
and he could pee all over the place
no it wasn't you're pretty accurate i
guess the worst part was the toy chest
was in the family room so great
one day my mom went there when she saw
that
my parents didn't find out and then one
day my mom's all why does it smell like
urine in here
you were storing the urine there in the
living room
it was just like this giant open
yeah essentially yeah and i just didn't
give a [ __ ]
god kids do the weirdest thing wow
i remember learning childhood psych that
like uh kids uh urination habits or
bathroom habits predict a lot about
their future
so i find that great oh well i was
[ __ ] up to begin with
you better keep a close eye on theodore
wait i don't know if we already know it
but are you into peeing on girls
me yeah
i mean i wouldn't say into it i've tried
it but it's oh you have tried it yeah we
talked about it oh yeah we've talked
about it yeah i've tried it i wouldn't
say
with whitney it was brought up but i
wasn't sure if we
it was in that conversation you're right
we actually wait would you get peed on
zach
uh i try yeah yeah you try
yeah but you haven't been peed on
i haven't been peed on a peed on someone
but did they like it
oh no
he just unplugged his internet
oh he's back did they like it zach i'm
here can you hear me yeah yes oh i get i
i guess in the moment yeah you know if
you're funny enough you'll do anything
you weren't like into it
i i
did you have a boner when you peed
because that's tough to do you can't pee
with them that's what i was going to ask
yeah
so you know that really you can't pee
with the bone and you told me i did not
well you can but it's like it's like you
have no accuracy very dangerous like
hitting the peak of mount everest yeah
you lose all
that happens every once in a while in a
video game and you can't aim yeah
you can try but many have failed
all so where do you keep your pee now
today zach
um i have a bottle in my room okay
you do that do you really
no
because i know people do that
yeah i actually have a friend who told
me actually i don't i won't reveal but
he told he tells me that he pees in
bottles
in the middle of the night because he
doesn't want to get up and he literally
has bottles of pee next to his bed i
swear to god you know who it is
i let the speculation begin no i won't
reveal any more info yeah
than that but i was shocked
have you ever drank pee
you know i have not drank and pee have
you zack
go ahead
please
after high school and i was with my
buddy wes and
we were at this party and we had to pee
so bad
yes had to pee so bad and we pissed in
this cup and there were like cigarette
butts in there and
our friend is like yo you guys should
drink it i'm like
okay
we just took a swig and
i'm just crazy like that you are crazy
like that dude he's just damaged you're
so young and you already have so many
stories to tell
yeah you got to keep a full sign zach
yeah i feel like if it wasn't for us
zach would be dead in the ditch
somewhere all right
we gotta keep an eye on this kid man
this week has been depressing so this is
a this is fun for me
um
depressing because ian is sick
yeah it's just kind of like with all the
oh it's your ending right
uh
i believe we have love on the line love
are you there
yo what's up okay hang on because we
didn't finish watching this clip let's
finish watching it
i'm serious why you know you know that i
i don't my i literally look and i see
and i said the shower is not where i
want to pee right now i want to pee in
the bathtub and i didn't did it
you know that i don't want you to pee in
there because i use it
is it across your mind that p also is a
germ killer
it did right
it did so why
because it's
it was kind of interesting
okay love how is that
a bit
pretty much everything they do is for
content and their whole stream
their farming content constantly and
that's the whole point
i don't have a like straight answer to
why it's fake but they fake a lot
so you think he's one of the biggest
streamer on twitch is the face of twitch
oh really you think he's open to
humiliating himself like that she seems
so genuinely disturbed
for sure he does
immediately uh
himself a lot
constantly
well thanks for ruining the video love
some people are wondering who is love
love is if you have seen him on twitter
he goes by h3 out of context
and
hi love we actually never we've never
spoken to love love is uh he works
full-time for us and he does all of our
social media
he's a he's the highlight god we love
love and he does h3 out of context he's
the man
how are you loved
peace and love he's in love
the live stream is perfectly at night in
sweden so
i usually just watch the podcast and
then go to bed
but
oh yeah
yeah what time is it there
well
it's uh 11 o'clock oh okay
love are you tell me about your life are
you single right now
yeah yes i am single
what do you mean you guys i was
expecting this question no he said yes
and
do you think it's hard to meet a girl
when you're such a h3 sim because you
are are you an h3 simp or do you have
other people's account you do out of
context for no i'm only
here for you dude really no no
yeah
that's a [ __ ] sin
i i would argue i'm a bigger sin than
maybe i didn't know that i thought that
you were whoa whoa i thought you that
you kind of do it for other people too
for some reason because there's out of
context for other people yes yeah
i thought it was one person
i won't
i'll say he deserves the crown i mean
like really maybe i'm gonna give it up
just like that dude wait wait
i'm more about the meme but i mean like
i haven't watched like every single h3
video one night and i know look okay
wait let's test him let's test it you
know i have noticed that a couple of
times a b didn't know the reference
about like
little things we've talked about or why
he failed he's a fake game and i was
like okay i see
oh just just to cut in real quick um
that guy miss gif is watching our stream
right now who's that oh he is
yeah so does he want to call in and yeah
because i want to know if this was fake
or not and he's being called out what's
his name
what is it yeah
yeah miss gif it's the face of twitch
it's the face of twitch what do you mean
he's the faithful player is that what he
says
here's the face of twitch that's it okay
all right
does it mean like twitch put him on
posters
he's one of the bigger streamers okay
okay miss gift so what's going on you're
being called out do you pee in the
shower can he call in is he interested
in calling it to the show
i guess uh what would be the best way
how do we do that i mean if he's in
discord i'll send him the i mean i doubt
he's a
subscribing member
um
maybe
um
email me
that's probably the easiest way and i
can reply with a link to what's your
email podcast today's your
productions.com sure maybe can we can we
dm them the zoom yeah maybe we should dm
oh let me call him on twitter yeah there
you go there you go okay so simple oh
trish is messaging me
i just want to get a peek
wait but we got so much going on yeah
but i just okay we got uh but yeah love
it's nice
not good
i appreciate you guys as well
um someone said in the chat we need to
do a simp off
that's what i want to do right now i i
was about to suggest that but then a b
just rolled over immediately
wait what's his twitter what's his
twitter miss gift probably just mischief
missed
m i
i am the man child on twitch proud owner
okay here i just i just followed him so
oh his his um his icon is a black
meme
right
so there you go
we're friends have you visited one of us
one of us one of us is he still watching
ian
yeah he's saying he wants to come on
okay so so so all right i just followed
you on twitter
one of us one of us
can you guys give ethan a link to give
him yes i uh sent it in our uh
link oh okay in our group chat yes sir
so it's ms kiff
m-i-m-i-z-k-i
that's fine okay i'm sending you the
zoom link and your twitter dms dude
you've got it there on your twitter dms
all right this is exciting you're a fan
of his two love
oh yeah big fun big fun so wait so wait
whoa whoa whoa
you gotta kill
one of us
i mean who are you a bigger fan of
because because like i
i know that you're a fan of ours but
like you know you're a fan of a lot of
people so you kind of gotta choose here
well i'm choosing you and the day of the
week of course but that's what what
about on the weekends
yeah
he says he's joining the zoom oh this is
amazing i love this by the way the
number that mischief has on the screen
and that's how many subscribers he has
that's right and that's paying
subscribers oh wow
wait that's not it that doesn't include
um
prime
okay all right he's uh in the lobby i'm
gonna work all right miss gif let's
let's talk about it
levels out of this later
all right yeah we'll settle this later
love
you know what we should do ian can you
put together a um a simp off contest for
the two of them yeah that we can do next
week
sure you write that down i gotta study
that
somebody wrote down
but no studying no way
wait do you guys want my camera yeah
yeah yeah if you got it we can throw you
on screen
yeah yeah yeah we need to see the face
of twitch
yeah oh my god that
twitter right here you read the article
okay
all right hold on i'm trying to make
this work start start i don't really use
zoom off and i'm a little uh
yeah
it's all good
yeah it takes a minute to do all the
clicks do it live sorry guys
i can't believe i'm talking this i'm a
huge fan
thank you so much dude yeah i'm a huge
fan i love your uh
uh oh i see you hey
we got it i am thank you guys all right
so let me try this this is my technician
okay what's the peeing so i have it on
good authority that the peeing bit was a
setup
uh why don't you talk to her because i'm
a huge pathological liar you are
is that what she says about you
he is a pathological life
okay so so did he be in the tub yes or
no
multiple times
why why does he do that
because he thinks it's more fun
why basement you think it's more fun
i kind of agree with on there he only
pees in the shower and then sometimes he
pees in the bathroom yeah i heard him
say like i didn't want to go through the
shower and i was like wait yeah do you
have life you never pee in the toilet
that's one thing we know for sure
he doesn't pee in the toilet now
well that's crazy bro you look i get the
feeling you're looking back and forth on
your stream and seeing yourself waving
is that what's going on
i don't think you can hear us because
she's oh she's got the headphones on
yeah okay okay dude ethan dude being on
your show boosting me up to a hundred
viewers man thank you so much only a
hundred we gotta do better than that
dude no way this is crazy dude thank you
so much okay wait all right wait so
you're huge
you're the face of twitch bro don't be
doing stick on me
so yeah you've heard oh we got gamer
glasses
oh yeah of course and sponsored
okay hold on hold on
hold on
so when you walked on and he quote
humiliated him
was that schtick was that planned no
you you talked to her there's nothing
okay
was it when you walked on and humiliated
him was that was not planned because
love here thinks it was planned
we're getting out the fireballs
no he was upset that i did that
so are you his caretaker like us yeah
yeah i could tell this guy neither i
recognize one when i see him
something tells me this guy needs even
more help than i do
yeah
he wipes his own ass though so that's
good that's huge progress
so so
so he pees in the tub but you don't want
him to pee in the tub has he stopped
peeing in the tub you prefer he pees in
the shower what is going on yeah i've
told him that i don't want him to pee in
the tub so before he said that he
wouldn't and then he did it again and
that's why i was mad so has he stopped
since that incident
uh yeah he hasn't done it since that's
great
he pees in the tub and he lets it dry
there like what's the situation can you
uh i don't know if on youtube they they
have they made timeouts yet or something
can you time out this one guy in your
chat who said hassana b is definitely
the face of twitch
they obviously haven't seen him play a
video game
we have the ability well well i was
another friend of the show i don't know
if yeah we can really be choosing sides
yeah i mean hassan well who do you want
to choose sides with the real face of
twitch or hassana b okay look he'll be
the face of twitch in four more years
but until then you're talking to him
well love well love here is a fan so
love you tell me who's the face of
twitch is it hassan or the or the uh or
uh whiz whiz what uh sorry i'm sorry
the tub pisser
no mischief is the face of twitch
there's no doll oh love says
dude this is crazy dude you guys are you
guys are not i don't understand why
you're so so hus why is it oh i see
sorry i'm trying to okay so tell me um
now that i've got you here
the face of twitch
are you glad the doc doctor was banned
because i feel like that probably gave
you a leg
[Laughter]
you want to know my honest opinion yeah
hell no
no way no there's not one person on
twitch who's happy that doc's gone
really
dude he
twitch is a dead platform man you're
doing the right thing being on youtube
we're out of jokes you know what i mean
we're out of memes
it's been it's been going on here for 10
years now
and uh doc was one of the only people
that had the good memes the good jokes
the good fun and now that he's go i'm
being honest now that he's gone i i know
twitch would agree
uh it's been pretty boring he's he was a
lot of the funny clips he was a lot of
the funny stuff and since he's gone it's
been kind of dead what what do you make
of like do you feel uneasy being on a
platform that just ban someone it
doesn't give any reason even now there's
no explanation
uh i feel like i have uh my leg and
enough dms where i don't really have to
care about that stuff so i'm kind of
okay you know i've uh
definitely made my friends and my
enemies but i've uh i think i'm okay
compared to the average i've uh done a
lot of good networking and i'm also
dating a bird girl who's loved by twitch
twitch loves her you're a bird girl well
she she does a podcast on twitch she's a
very animal loving person oh we love
animals so you're you have a good you
have an in-road so basically
basically you're saying you're
unbannable
oh
pretty much yeah i mean i
i do every bounty for them i run ads for
them they love me over here and then she
just does she literally is the perfect
angel
she's the bird face of twitch he's she
is the bird face of twitch yeah he's
great
and so i understand you play um nintendo
games you played old nintendo games are
we
um
why are we living in the past
honestly because the pass was better man
let's just cut to the chase i mean like
i think the 90s were look i mean
the best you wait do you guys like uh
nintendo yeah i can't believe i'm
talking you guys i feel like i'm in a
dream
tell me how cool this is
that's sick oh
oh it's
wait tell me about the rating
so it's a
god that's my favorite part this is tell
me everything i'm really interested tell
us all the nerds
i collect
i collect uh boxes graded boxes like vj
graded in boxes that are graded because
this is my this is what i love to do so
i live in the past completely um yeah
what's that worth how do you yeah what
does it work
it's worth about
i'm sorry this is just my this is just
my youtubes no one cares about that uh
this is worth about like uh like ten
thousand dollars wow whoa
yeah oh cool and what's it rated on the
on this scale
uh it's 85 plus
so it has the uh the gold standard so
that and my bathtub you know
right right
and by the way can we talk about that i
don't leave
the piss in there what is the first
problem oh you don't toilet
the okay the you want to know the real
issue and this is not
i've talked to her off stream about this
maybe ethan i feel like you understand
right you have adhd i'll try eighty it
would people call me h3
right right so you have adhd listen
it's on the toilet kind of boring right
like you go to the toilet you're peeing
and you're like tick-tock on the clock
you're looking at yourself just peed in
my basement it i dude when i was a kid i
used to pee in my sink in my basement
because it's i used to be in the sink a
lot
see then you're not you're not watching
i don't do it since i've been married
though you know what i mean like doesn't
go we're not married yet right we
haven't announced it yet yeah yeah yeah
so yeah so are you pledging to her today
that once you get married the unusual
peeing habits will stop
do you pledge today that once you get
married the urine will only go in the
toilet
being in the tub is part of the bachelor
life and uh
yeah man i'm only i'm only 19. i don't
know if i can get married yet oh you're
young man
i'm young wait how old are you i'm old
as [ __ ] we're like 50.
i'm 35.
yeah i know
jesus i'm surprised you're not using
teamspeak for this call
[Laughter]
you guys are old as hell wait i have a
question if i ever came to la would i be
able to go on your show
if there's no culvert i'll bring you on
yeah [ __ ] it let's go we're friends yeah
no way really
we should play some mario or something
you're trolling dude would you play a
video game or something yeah i'm down
i think we have a good vibe we could be
in the tub together
and we can play let's get back to that
so just letting you guys know when i pee
in the tub first of all it uh eliminates
all germs i'm letting you guys know
that's [ __ ] that's a [ __ ]
that's not true
hear them out hear them out here
that's not true it's not true
[Laughter]
i've watched a lot of tech talks about
it yeah
when you pee in the tub i'm just letting
you guys know so you're cleaning the top
you think you think urinating cleans it
so i've watched a lot of tick tocks and
i'm not 19. how old are you dude
how old do i look 37.
you old [ __ ]
talking [ __ ] about me
oh he's 25 okay
all right
he's going to pee in the bait he's going
to be in the bathtub god
he's going to be in the bathtub go check
on him okay
we don't buy that well ethan okay
all right you're 25 you look 25
i'm 25. yes wait how does she look
she's older than me i'm not answering
that don't put me in that position
no i want to put you in that position
okay
i think she looks uh 24.
24. i'm 22. she's 22. oh see that you're
close yeah that's close
dude i can't believe i'm talking to you
guys you guys are like famous famous and
we're like
we're not the face of anything yeah
definitely i just i'm telling you all i
do is just i just leach off of other
streamers
[Laughter]
huh well hold on let me ask you
something
your icon what is the your twitter icon
uh
yeah it's not brand friendly i should
probably change it isn't that from blast
yeah so we're fans of that four years in
the making
yeah it's so what it is it's
uh that's my face in the picture
it is uh yeah that's me no it's not yes
it is
so would you you want to get black
uh that's me when i was five years old
[Music]
makes sense he's lying
i'm not i don't trust anything you say
you're one of these guys that just lies
about everything you're on traffic video
about me no i swear to god
it's me when i was five years old i was
in a mets outfit and i had a bat and i
took that face and i put on the pictures
and that's there
and what's with the black hand cresting
your face well it sounds like you're
facing oh that's my father
yeah we're at a baseball game yeah of
course
so wait would you guys play mario party
or something with us yeah 100
wait he
he
so
i feel like you like animals right
yes i love animals
maya a question maya has a podcast
she do she doesn't have a pod would you
ever go on her podcast you just
networking i mean what the [ __ ] i'm
trying to talk with you you just try to
network this [ __ ]
i mean i mean pace yourself buddy you're
gonna host me afterwards
i mean what the [ __ ] man
just trying to leverage everything but i
appreciate the hustle i don't
but that's not a hustle
but i do i do think we have a good vibe
and i would like to play video games
with you
that would be sick wait what kind of
games do you what's your favorite video
i've made if i you have to prove to me
that you're actually a fan what's my
favorite video
what's your favorite video of mine go
ahead five seconds
name one video i've made name one video
i've made oh come on dude do you
well i used five seconds back in the day
with like vape national like come on
name one other one
oh when you attacked keemstar do we
watch those on stream okay okay i think
we watched all of them like the winter
of the keemstar the summer of keemstar
early spring of keemstar
gardens got some credentials
video older than one year old go other
than vape nation at keemstar go five
seconds when you attack james charles
because uh he stole your your brand okay
that's not no i wasn't old but it's
really it sounds like i like you he's
familiar yeah i like it i watched uh uh
i i watched your doctor disrespect uh
h3h3 podcast oh there you go okay okay
even brideberry ethan bradberry who can
forget right there
one of my favorite videos is when you
were color you you people are typing in
the chat people are typing in the chat
and you're cheating
man i only have a hundred viewers right
it's not helping much all right
are you joey salads can i ask you
something yeah you're just reading off
[ __ ] did your views go up from this
did my views go up from this yeah
no
[Laughter]
they did that's good i'm glad
mine did too i think you got to host me
this is good really we should do this
more often because our views all of our
views went up
wait can i ask you a question yeah
anything
why don't you do this on twitch
the real answer which i will i'm always
honest so i'll be honest with you right
now
is that the
twitch was paying me money
to stream there
and they and then when it was time to
renew
the contract they were being really
annoying
and youtube offered to pay me more money
so i said [ __ ] you twitch i'm going to
daddy youtube
that's it
but i will say
the the monetization on twitch is so
much better with the prime the prime
[ __ ] is so awesome
you know yeah i wish i saw that more
often honestly but we come from youtube
it makes more sense
no it makes perfect sense i i but your
your podcast was pretty good over here
it was like the second best podcast on
twitch really who's it was better the
bird one
yeah the bird one's pretty yeah
anyway i'm happy on youtube i already
pissed in tubs i don't want to get more
in trouble yeah yeah
anyway i like being on youtube because
it makes sense because all of our
content lives here so there's no
transporting or anything needed there's
a lot of problems like for example we
would stream
on twitch and then because of the
contract we had with twitch we had to
wait a day and so people would upload it
on youtube before ours went up on
youtube and it would [ __ ] up the content
id because google would think that they
made the original video so it was a
whole that was kind of a whole mess
there too but you know
you don't have emotes and stuff you know
we
hit him with the emojis guys
spam those motions
[Laughter]
trisha sent me a bunch of angry texts
after the beginning of our lives i'm i'm
watching a new video yeah
oh for real
she already put up a video i'm done with
h3n oh [ __ ] me all right guys we gotta
go deal with something
oh [ __ ]
wait what was that was jake paul on
what's going on
zach hit the the the uh
the ring the bell ring anyway dude it
was really nice meeting you i like i
like you i like both you i think you
guys are great i like that you have a
caretaker i like that you be in the
bathtub and the sink and everything i'm
down with that i think it's fantastic
wait so but you so
are you guys really down to hang out
sometime wait don't you live in new york
no no we're in la oh wait oh yeah forgot
about that didn't you live in new york
we did at one point yes
oh i'm from jersey oh yeah but we're not
there anymore
i i just was trying to you know relate
it's friendly with you guys yeah
your water supply and trash goes to my
state
it's a beautiful it's a beautiful uh
uh relatable chopper yeah so listen
follow me on twitter if you ever come to
la or whatever or whatever let's play
some video games let's play some mario
oh no way i love it
mario would you want to play mario is it
mario or mario you tell me
it's mario that's what i think too
how do you say water
i say water
radiator
coffee how do you say coffee i love you
you don't say it like that do you
i i i'm looking at my coffee right now
oh no
i mean
i'm looking at your girlfriend's face to
try to tell when you're bullshitting me
or not
you might as well just talk to her
because she's just the honest truth
does he really say coffee
and dog and water
okay thank you for the clarification
and i also say toilet when i'm looking
at a bathtub
all right we gotta go we have a crisis
on our hands
thank you for calling in i appreciate
that
and uh we'll we'll talk to you okay
we'll play some mario
dude hell yeah you guys are the best i
love this it's crazy yeah this was fun
thanks for calling in you guys are
awesome nice meeting you guys
all right bye guys love you talk to you
thank you guys god bless you guys merry
christmas merry christmas dude i'll see
you guys
happy hanukkah i'll send you guys some
bathroom cleaning products
i'll send you guys some top scrub stuff
thank you thank you yeah you're welcome
you're welcome anything anything
anything to help you guys all right take
care anything for a fan i love you guys
bye
thank you that was fun what a nice guy
that was great huh what a character good
call
love yeah love are you still with us
yes yes
how'd that go love
i think that went well uh he didn't
leech off you too much yeah
yeah he tried just a little he was
trying man
but
yesterday he had 70k viewers on twitch
70k what was he doing yeah he was
like twitch has been hit with a
pokemon card like opening spree
yeah so he's doing critical and everyone
is doing it so he saw that
a guy
opened a pokemon box that's like 20
years old for i think i think it's like
20 or 30k dollars
he's so rich sort of open is one of the
oldest streamers he burned all the cards
that they opened just to whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa wait
miss kif did that
no no no
another guy soda pop he did that that's
so good his
neighbors with uh
pretty much
and how did how did the viewers react to
the burning that seems kind of over the
top
well
it's that's so not helping for you
so
um
well that was fun that wouldn't happen
without love so thank you love we love
the love we love the love connection
okay so so like next week let's get love
back on the phone because i want to have
a sip off between love and yeah
roger that so next friday are you
available
um yeah of course okay i understood good
that's how i like it
okay thank you i'm not studying though
no nobody should die
you could study like i'm studying look
if you if you study that means your
dedication yeah it shows dedication
i mean i don't want to do anybody like
that if eb once said i want to
okay so so be here next friday okay i
love we appreciate you thank you and
that was really great thanks for for
making that happen that was awesome
yeah thank you guys for everything
that's a [ __ ] scene all right hey
buddy okay now i had all this stuff
planned but i think we have to watch
trisha's new video live
oh that's probably not a great idea why
well abe watched it right
it's it's 18 17 minutes i'm five minutes
let's watch it how's it going
i don't think you damn i feel like it's
meant to be watched right now
yeah
okay like come on this is way too good
okay so the title is so done with h3 and
their hypocrisy and lies
well brother
i feel like we were really fair i know
like we're literally just saying exactly
what happened that's it let me read her
text because she sent me a bunch says
let me i think that will inform
inform what happened she said well i'm
not going to read her text out of
respect for her but i think she just
what triggered her i'm
in her defense i'm guessing is the chat
oh it wasn't reading the chat
she said i was really uh pro ela
yeah
uh
huh
she said she's always trying to hang out
outside the podcast that's not true
she says
she quits
i'm making a video
whatever let's watch right now h3 and
honest
here we go buckle up ladies and
gentlemen
let's go
buckle in boys
this might be the end of frenemies right
before our eyes
like honestly i'm done i'm honestly done
with frenemies yeah yeah we were
supposed to try and do a doctor dr
episode next week or whatever but i'm
i'm seriously freaking done um my
security guard's behind me right now
sorry he just like came in but um i'm so
freaking i'm so freaking done with them
because honestly
honestly they didn't even watch the full
video of what i put out
and i am so [ __ ] sick of one of ela
being so [ __ ] mighty or holier than
thou i deserve to not be talked about
and all this [ __ ] like that so did we at
the beginning of our relationship so did
we at the beginning of when me and moses
started dating they talked wait
this is just not a good comparison they
were on the dating show i know this is
so not the same
like maybe i leaked something that they
didn't think i should have but
but like on a personal level she's
dating our brother we want to know
what's going on it all started from him
telling us he was gonna apply just for
for the show he all started like that he
was in on it i feel like exactly i feel
like both of them are kind of rewriting
his story and now that they're together
they like have this romantic idea of how
it all started moses that was not what
happened moses was like i'm going to
apply
for the show to be interesting and we
were the one
he was actually asking us like what
should i say you want me to be funny you
want this and and we were like just do
your thing just be yourself
i remember it very vividly
so no wonder we talked about it it was
meant for the show dude the comparison
is ridiculous like i i once they said we
decided not to talk about anymore and
that was good i didn't want to but now
all we asked of her was not to talk
about moses's family just
stop sharing private details about what
moses is telling you about his family
because it's hurting people
like that's it people are saying it's
buffering for them
yeah
i think our internet was having a little
bit of a
rocky ride for a second it seems to have
stabilized
yeah it's not flashing anymore is
everyone saying the chat in the chat
then it's all good
um i guess i don't know i guess that's a
little delayed but i think we're okay
it's not it was so much relentlessly
about me and she's like what's the joke
what's the joke about my family not
being invited it's a [ __ ] joke no
it's not oh my god
why is how is it a joke i don't
understand
how is saying moses doesn't even like
you guys anyway while you're angry a
joke
how are you going to write that as a
joke and you keep saying it we're not
engaged we're not getting married
there's no wedding right now it's a
[ __ ] joke so to be like what wait you
guys are definitely trying to get
pregnant and you just bought a house
together so why how is it how is you
guys getting married a joke like what's
the joke what's the joke i mean joke
what's so funny about that hey guess
what [ __ ] ethan and ela that's what
you guys signed up for you guys want to
be on the show and you guys use this to
get views and we got the million views
and whatever and like i'm fine with that
i'm fine being exploited i'm fine being
exploited not being exploited
i don't know she i feel like when she
gets into this um
episodes she doesn't even mean what she
says that's kind of so i don't even know
if i should even react because obviously
i didn't even i didn't even respond to
her comments about our parenting
right that she made yeah
i don't even want to go there if we
really are going to think each other's
top comment is so perfect trisha you
don't talk about your own brother
because he doesn't want you to
and i respected that i was like okay
fine so how come you can't
give either that same respect
you know
but i feel like
my mom does not want to be part of the
internet and everything that we do in in
this way
and so and and trisha knows that
my brother have told told her that my
mom asked that from the beginning she
just don't want to be a part of this
stuff she has her she likes her privacy
she likes living a normal regular life
and she doesn't want to become
anything other than what she is used to
and so
i mean she should be able to understand
my request this isn't me being
high and mighty and snobby and i don't
know whatever she's saying about me it's
not that at all i share everything about
myself
and i was gonna be in front of me so in
the next episode like she was saying
like i'm too good for the show it's like
i i've told her that i'm personally a
fan of this show
it's i don't know it's like there's just
no winning
with her i think like and it's not her
fault necessarily because i know she has
this condition yeah totally have empathy
for
but when you tell her something like
don't talk about my mom this is off
limits then i think when she goes to
that place then she knows how to get to
you because she's like i'm not supposed
to talk about this so this is the thing
i'm going after
and i'm not saying i'm even gonna give
her a pass and say it's not her fault
because of her condition but i'm just
saying that
she still does it
and this claim that we exploit her i
don't understand how is it exploiting
i'm paying like i pay you
i welcome you i built this whole [ __ ]
set
everything we do is consensual i don't
understand how you can claim that i
exploit you you literally always tell me
that this show's the only reason you're
relevant and it's the only reason you
like youtube and all this [ __ ]
we're so out front and honest with
everything we
do pokes on it but don't be like what's
the joke it's not funny oh i didn't know
you guys are the [ __ ] comedy gods
that get to decide what's funny what's a
joke wasn't appropriate what's
interesting what is the joke i mean
you're saying it's a joke but what's the
joke i think that's a that's a good
question
ethan be like this isn't entertaining
well clearly it [ __ ] is because it
gets more [ __ ] views on your channel
than any other one of your shitty ass
podcasts she always goes to that she's
always trying to like i know yeah
yeah it's entertaining it's good content
but
she she she thinks that that hurts my
feelings or something but
it's entertaining people like it i mean
i'm fine with that i like it too
i'm so
[ __ ] sick of these people i'm so
[ __ ] sick of it and i'm so done and i
literally don't care i literally don't
care yes we buried the hatchet yes we
said i'm sorry to each other yes i was
over it but i was allowed to make a
video in response to the comments i was
getting and if they actually [ __ ]
watch the video they would get that hey
ethan and eli not everything is a
personal attack against you they were
their big thing that they were so
offended is that i pinned a comment on
my video that i posted this morning
the comment was and he sent me he sent
me a whatsapp and i got and i sent it
back and he saw it he said he started 12
43. so he saw this while filming the
live
it's in this comment people keep
praising ethan
but to be honest they're just as toxic
as david and his gang was they poke
treasure in ways that they know we'll
get a rise out of her and don't fully
communicate with her dude that's our
show that's what we do and that's what i
do but the minute i [ __ ] poke or i
say a joke that he doesn't mind dude
it's not she's not getting it
no it's not a joke it's not entertaining
it's not getting ready you're [ __ ]
with their family you're [ __ ] with
their family that's not a joke it's not
entertaining and it's not okay
or offensive
it's totally just like her brother
situation my family did not sign up for
this and they don't want to be a part of
this and she knows that even dr drew
when we had him on set you guys have to
have boundaries right
and the boundary that we set is you
gotta stop talking about
moses and ila's family and ela
or about how moses feels about eel and
all this [ __ ] you gotta stop
she didn't respect that boundary she
immediately
you know broke [ __ ] crushed it like
the kool-aid man
you know what i mean
then he embarrasses me then i'm the
[ __ ] crazy one i crossed the line
it's not funny what driving a wedge in
our family is not funny driving or
watching between our [ __ ]
relationship at the beginning is not
funny either i never once asked you guys
to talk about my podcast i'm asking
moses specifically asked you he led us
to have ethan stop talking about him and
what did you say what did you say to
moses you said that's the joke it's part
of the show we he has [ __ ] text
messages
moses doesn't have a voice in this you
guys have this platform and you guys you
didn't even watch the [ __ ] video but
they take this as a personal attack this
comment oh me pinning and tweeting
i don't even know i'm not following yeah
i don't think we can watch it i don't
know that we should watch this yeah and
people in the chat are saying it just
feels too bad
well
this is the problem too is like i don't
know what to do with this situation but
it's obviously gotten a little out of
hand at this point
you know i thought it was all good and
then and then i saw that comment and it
made me feel like well
clearly it's not all good right if she's
saying they're as toxic as david and his
group and again i'm not calling david
and his group talks i don't know what
happened with them but like i know how
she feels about them
and so if she feels that same way about
us then what's the point of this whole
thing
you know
i don't know
hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah i was really hoping we could
make it work you know i felt like
i felt like the trials and the
tribulation and everything was part of
the show and that we would overcome
everything and make it work but
yeah
if that is going to be happening now
frankly
i mean she like i feel like her and
everyone
who follows her kept saying how you know
that's what happens to all of her
relationships and i guess
i feel like we're seeing it happen in
front of us because
we really
wanted it to work we weren't doing
anything to like try and make it not
work
the opposite
to make it work and i thought you know
what i can do this i can do this because
i'm patient with her and i don't take
the things she says personally so i can
do this where other people maybe
got to the limit with her i can endure
it and i can do this and we can work
through it but she finds a way to make
it she she somehow always finds a way
right i can't talk to her past
relationship but she found a way with me
to make it unmanageable
because it it can
because there's no limit so it's like if
you're unfair then she brings in the
family right
she attacks our parenting
she'll and well the parenting thing
didn't bother me honestly that much
because
i know that it was unwarranted but the
family thing is just it's causing it's
causing problems you know what i mean
like
[ __ ] you want to watch some crazy videos
or you want to wrap it up how long we've
been going dan
uh about two hours
we got to bring in the um the only fans
people that we
that we uh
had on
cleanse the palette with some funny
videos or something though okay good
call there's some really good videos
here
i don't know how to feel about that like
i feel bad for her that i don't know
i don't know what to say about it you
know it's like okay she did her video we
responded i feel like we didn't really
say anything better but we were just
kind of explaining what happened
right
um
right then and abe i mean what did what
did i do
you talking about now or right now
oh right i think it was more of the chat
i feel like she felt more attacked by
the chat really i don't know i didn't i
don't think so i mean i mean we you guys
probably should have watched her video
she she actually had a point with that
we were commenting on a 45 minute long
video that we didn't
watch oh well av watched the whole thing
okay but it's not
it's not about a b
you got you got some bullet points on it
and there may have been some nuance i
don't know i haven't watched the video
either but i mean i just saw the
comments you pinned well but what set
her off and what caused her to make this
further video is we made a large
commentary on a video that you didn't
even watch which i think to her
i i think that that was triggering her
no i don't think so i mean
we talked about the video we talked
about all the stuff that happened
leading to this yeah
i don't know i didn't talk about the
video yeah i said i didn't watch it i
just talked about the comments she
pinned and i was talking about
everything leading up to our last
episode of frenemies
but i'll watch the video i'll watch the
video
i mean she posted it this morning i
didn't have time to watch it this
morning
but i'll watch it afterwards but like
you know i didn't talk about her video
okay i should have watched her video i
mean still i don't know we didn't have
time
dude i give her i feel like i give her
all the credit in the world i give her
all the benefit of the doubt every time
i mean what the [ __ ]
do i not
have ever been unfair to her i don't
understand
no i think you've been really patient
with her i mean it
honestly i think
in retrospect it's easy to say this
obviously but what set off that fight
the other day of you interjecting
mid-episode to
uh lay down that restriction about
conversation about ela probably should
have happened in advance
and um i think well okay that's true but
i don't think she would have i think she
would have taken her horribly to no
matter what and she probably would have
brought it up on the show but you're
right i should have told her i should
have told her ahead of time right and
overall
i'm not trying to take her side in any
of this but i'm just trying to see where
there may have been missteps then and
that's why
that's why i
when i finished watching it my first
realization was that i should have just
said it to her myself right right
because
yeah and you know i guess ethan didn't
know when would be the right time to say
something like that
and you know
but i i thought it would be okay i don't
know why i thought it would be okay to
do it like
like hey what was impromptu and and it
was going a place where you knew it
couldn't and so you you tried to
you know
draw a line in the sand right there is
there any comments or donations that we
should read we haven't done any of those
a lot
maybe are you tracking anything
i am but i only have limited amount that
i could keep track of because i'm not on
the back end and i i can see some of
them well can you write them down good
one you should just jot down good ones
like copy paste them in the future
uh do you want me to just read some off
here i mean i would prefer if they're
curated a little bit oh okay
you know i mean it's all about right now
yeah
well i'm curious if people have insights
i don't know if they do or not
uh ethan trisha's brain works in a way
that's different from how your brain
works she needs specialized help yeah
you won't be able to uh i agree to cope
it out so easy and that's what i agree
with and i i don't know how to handle
this situation i've never been in a
situation like this
and
yeah i am well aware that's why i'm the
first
guardian
i was gonna say i feel like the first
step is this has got to be taken offline
like it messes with you when you make a
point and then you've got like a live
ticking feed of people going you're
wrong or you're right and then it it
alters what you do next and i think
we're just going we're getting in this
back and forth cycle that's kind of
being pushed
by the conversations happening by all
these people we don't know the metadata
i think are kind of influencing yeah i
think we got to just take it off the
line
well we'll definitely take it off
yeah i agree we'll take it offline for
sure after this
i mean
i to the point about her mind working
differently i get that and i totally
empathize with that night that's why i
just i don't know what to do and how to
help her but
i think we just need some time at this
point to let things settle
yeah definitely
yeah no
but it it did it hurt it just hurt my
feelings a little bit that comment about
us being as toxic as david's gang
because like i said i don't know how i
can't speak to that what they actually
did so i'm not trying to say they're
toxic i'm just saying i know how she
feels about them and the fact that she
feels that way about us was kind of
just i don't know because it kind of
hurts my feelings because i feel like
i've been a good friend to her and i've
tried to do everything i can to be a
good friend and be supportive and
understanding and
i don't know what else i can do except
just give us some time i guess but yeah
i think trisha is really sweet she means
well and i feel like it's
you put a lot of understanding in on
your side and
you might not get that back like i feel
like anyone who knows you knows you're
very blunt and you know you're very
sincere when you speak and i feel like
she
she she's not giving you that she's not
allowing you to be yourself as well so
when you made the comment about like you
know just saying like bluntly like eli
doesn't be talked about she gets so
offended she doesn't give you that same
understanding
i hope it works out i
i like trisha i also agree with you abe
i think she has really good intentions
at heart and how hard she's a really
good person and that's why
i cherish my friendship with her and i
thought that we could work through
everything and so
i hope that you know given some time
things will settle and we can work it
out
because i do i i believe that she's a
good person you know and and that's why
i always
uh wanted to make it work
you know
i think everyone just needs some air and
take a step back
all right let's let's let's watch some
goofy videos
there's some great ones here
man i can't believe how great that
girlfriend peeing in the tub one went eh
that was awesome
yeah yeah
oh this one was so good you guys i saw
this i think i saw it on tick tock my
peep in my basement thank you uh uh
jeremy look watch this guy dude he'd
literally just you react to this i'm not
gonna say anything
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm not gonna say anything either
what
oh my god
i'm not gonna say anything okay
[Music]
no
no
wow
[Music]
that
oh oh
man
you gotta love this cameraman right he's
like oh
look at this guy this is a coach yeah
he's digging it oh he's got something
he's got a nugget
he's got a little nugget watch this
what
no
wait there's another one
i couldn't believe what i was saying oh
my god oh he hit so then he was forced
to make an apology because this video
went viral
how did it feel he had to address it
wow
does this have subtitles
i don't know you guys know i don't speak
uh you don't speak german you were
talking last week about it i'm not good
enough okay here we go
all right let's try this
is it just going to be auto generated
and yeah nonsense it's pretty good i
think
[Music]
i didn't know that people paid so much
attention to it
it happened and i'm sorry for it
and concentrating he needs to keep that
hand above the desk which you don't
perceive consciously
i'm trying to behave differently i'm
going to try and behave differently from
now on
it's so embarrassing just think whenever
you shake hands with someone bro i can't
believe they forced him to address it
it's like let's just say like that's one
of those things you just have to forget
happened and move on you know
can you though
you have to what else do you say
i mean he handled it well i guess though
yeah
and everyone smiles their man muscles i
mean sure i scratch my balls and smell
it but that guy was like all over up in
that spot
no i don't know no that's the butt no
neck
what do i smell my ass you hit your ass
when you smell your finger yeah
i mean sometimes really
yeah like you touch yourself you touch
your b-hole like really touch
no i mean not like you know sometimes
you know you not finger yourself but you
touch your feet
yeah you know why you want to make sure
you're clean down there aren't you
worried about your hands being dirty
yeah no i'm very clean down there
like will you touch your butt
i mean you poop from there
this is why i won the heartthrob thing
doesn't have anything to do with look
well something i'll go [ __ ] yourself
baby i'll be honest some people are into
this this is why people like zach i'm a
human being i mean we're related to apes
somewhat you know me too
you've never been curious to smell your
ass you know
ian's got his cat's arse in his face
right now yeah he smells his cat's house
so in when you're out and about
when you're out and about you'll touch
your b-hole no it's not when i'm out of
not when i'm out and about okay yeah i'm
not shaking your hand that's what i was
gonna say because you you're out and
about with your b-hole stink on your
fingers exactly
no i'm very clean you know it's it's a
smell check you know it's like a vibe
check
i'm trying to find some other good ones
good fire video on the subreddit oh for
real send it to me why was that i was i
was trying to be low-key ask the guys to
find it okay this one ela again i kind
of want your snap judgment on this
man since the invent the invention of
like
camera phones you've captured weird [ __ ]
man like you know seriously here's a
dude just eating a raw rack of ribs
and like a baseball field
love the meat chef
can you even chew it like how do you
even do that
and he just like plops it on the ground
it looks like a zombie invading invasion
yeah totally
there's the police siren going on
oh
i guess he's hungry i mean
this dude's just filming he can't
believe what he's seen man yeah
crazy
just shocked me i was like wow
[Music]
oh this one cracked me up too human jump
rope
so
he's spinning him around like he hates
him right
like he hates him his ass and then watch
how he throws him at the end whoa
like he [ __ ] hates that it looks like
an ape yeah he's scary this guy he's
he's trying to kill these people
[Applause]
i like to think that like
that everyone else is he's not playing
and everyone else is just goofing on him
he's like this berserk ape
then he just throws him at the end and
then he's going to rip everybody apart
whoa
that's crazy right
oh we have a flame video okay let's go
where is it
i got it
well look how this
this
spins
never seen that before
okay here we go
oh this is a fire mishap
now is this like include like graphic
burning of death because that's not what
i'm into
can somebody vet this did anybody watch
it did somebody yes
i watched or i i didn't watch the last
10 seconds why didn't you watch the last
time those are probably pretty critical
you can't set me up like this if i took
ten more seconds hold on hold on hold on
just this is a serious note
we're live you can't set me up like this
right
you can't send me a video someone
burning alive you have to watch it first
you won't even shake my hand ap
okay so did you watch it
it's loading it's loading now
when i seen the it didn't look like it
was
no it's me watch it just great okay all
right
fire in the pants oh he like fits it out
that's cool
what
[Applause]
oh no
[Music]
backstage
dude
i'm sorry but
that definitely was it
[Applause]
the dude was literally jerking it with a
fire stick like look at this he's like
let's go
[Music]
i mean what was the expectation
[Applause]
that's good not as good as the turkish
one i'll say but good
it's hard to find fire videos with the
perfect balance between hilarity and not
burning to death
right
it's a rare breed
it's that perfect venn diagram
[Music]
um
champagne anyone oh i didn't this is so
silly this is a silly video that i love
that was cracking up so much
it bounced off the wall and bounced off
his head and then it it's just it's so
funny
it's like such a three stooges thing
[Laughter]
in this slide whistle
yeah come on back let's get some cartoon
[ __ ] he gave you the the concept
[Laughter]
you love it
somebody donated a hundred dollars
australian for the fire safety video are
we just gonna end up watching them every
week you guys want me to watch the fire
safe the last time i didn't even laugh
though i had 100 big ones for that wow
we have so much stuff left to get to but
i gotta probably call it a day i'll
watch that for you though oh let's get
that okay let me watch the fire safety
video because i don't want to
i want to give you your money's worth
but i'm not i didn't even laugh anymore
i've just seen it too many times
but okay you paid for it i paid for it
you know turkish
fire
safety video
now this is my favorite
this is my favorite video
straight up
i got to put an embargo on pay me to do
this so cause we have 40 000 people
watching the donuts really want to watch
this video for the 20th time
so we've got the turkish
fire fighters
you know they're doing some kind of uh
presentation
not going great
and this guy this is like the chief of
fire apparently in turkey and well he
catches himself on fire and then he
throws it on everybody
which is so funny
because it's he's there to put the fire
out
and he's throwing it on people
and it looks intentional too
also whatever what could they possibly
be demonstrating you know it's like that
he just set some logs on fire
this guy is the worst fireman ever i
think that's what's so funny about it
besides the fact that it looks like he
did it intentionally he's the worst
fireman ever
this guy looks so perfect like when you
get upgraded attacks you know in a video
game it's totally level three fire
attack
level three fire attack for sure
he's like hey
hey dude catch this
catch
catch this fire [ __ ]
you're the fireman you're not supposed
to be lighting people on fire
he literally left people on fire
all right don't send me that anymore
don't make me do that anymore please
that's it that's the last time that's it
don't don't donate with peace and love
yeah with peace and no further
videos
any further
training video requests will be thrown
in the bin after december 11.
no more donations
in the name of fire safety video any
further donations will be returned with
peace and love
thank you thank you thank you thank you
thank you
all right we're almost at two and a half
hours oh yeah yeah there's so much more
to get to but it's been too long
it's been 10 weeks look at me
that is
so what should we do on tuesday because
that's our next
oh well we should discuss after yeah
yeah really we shouldn't do this live
yes well there'll be something i think
so for sure because i don't want to i
got it something dr drew would
definitely be making an appearance the
personality test on tuesday
yeah question is will trisha be there
that is
the question i still hope i hope there's
a way i really do
it's been yeah it's been
where you look at me did i get acclaimed
for singing this too good
so ela happy birthday
thank you you look great today i know
you're having a bad like hair day but i
think you called it off the cliff i
always love when you put in the clip
people are gonna think that you he's
saying it because i was complaining
before
what i always compliment your looks no
i'm just i just don't want people to
think that you were just saying i have a
bad hair day out of nowhere
oh i'm protecting you oh
thank you
your hair looks great though everybody
was complimenting here the shirt's sick
too
appreciate it not as sick as ian
ian happy three year anniversary
we love you i love i love the cat
cuddles like
thank you god bless god bless
and
uh he just sent me okay abby just
reminded me we have to address um the
intern application uh oh situation oh
[ __ ] oh what about the only fans
girl well what about it
oh maybe we'll do it next time should we
bring her on
it's a whole thing yeah no i mean next
week next week next week with peace and
love next week peace and love
we will talk to you next week peace and
love
uh yeah we made a mention on the show
last week about a potential well there
was sort of a loose conversation going
on about
needing
having a possible need to staff up in a
couple months when we move into our new
studio as well as
the sort of uh desire to have
another female cast member on the show
and um
i guess the audience perceived that as a
call-out for applications of which we
have now received
about like 700 i would say oh my god in
my email
um so i apologize if i haven't responded
to yet um with peace and love with peace
and love
uh it's in love peace and love if if and
when i should when we are uh staffing up
we will we will explicitly call out for
that it will probably be in a few months
things are a little fluid because we're
still in the the pandemic mode
but we are moving into a much bigger
studio and we likely will be needing
help and i'm i'm saving all the
applications so you haven't wasted your
time by uh sending them in uh just to
make that clear but take your time don't
rush it because we're not reading them
all right now anyway that's right so
just wanted to clarify any further
resumes will be tossed in the bin no no
i am categorizing them all as applicants
uh none of them are being thrown away we
will review i will not read any
applications received after december
12th peace and love peace and love
so that's it just wanted to put that out
there
peace and love i know what it's like to
apply to something and not hear back uh
we're not ignoring you it's just maybe a
little uh there's a lot it was more than
we expected it was way more than we
expected all of our emails
like literally i just have to say all
every one of our emails is full yeah of
applications which is email my personal
oh i'm sure you're reminding me
that so many people are interested yeah
i kind of goofed up because our support
team and teddy fresh is really slammed
because ever since black friday it's
just been like
chaos for them and they're trying really
hard so
um
if anyone wanna apply for anything for
teddy fresh email to careers
teddyfresh.com
not support not support because they
careers teddyfresh.com is the new place
with peace and love yeah
any resume sent to support
well
that was great i mean hey thanks for
just sticking around it was fun episode
besides you know the tricia stuff which
is tough but hopefully we'll figure it
out but really enjoy talking to wiz kiff
the face of twitch i forget his name
biscuit
i get the feeling he's not a real school
anyway
[Laughter]
i get the feeling that guy didn't know
anything about me he was just reading
the chat no
yeah right he was like oh vape nation
and well anyway i like him regardless
yeah
you know what i mean
i know what you mean
all right well we'll be back on tuesday
and uh with peace and love have a great
weekend
wait didn't we get a christmas update to
the song you said maybe
jingle bells [ __ ]
[Music]
all right guys
i gotta take these
out
[Music]
rice from the ashes like the phoenix on
the flex back to zoo
[Music]
you're watching h to the three three
three three you're watching h two three
three three three you're watching h two
three three three you're watching h23
i'm